the storyline for the braves very simple
jeff you mentioned it a moment ago the
pitching's been great charlie morton
hopes to round back into shape and
hopefully the braves bats will do some
damage something toronto's lineup did in
the first two games of this series gate
down the field line somehow popped open
leave it to marcel to shut it
that's great somebody's hollering at
scott berry to run down the left field
line and go get the gate he said i'm not
going all the way down there
that way marcel
his first assist of the day
that's got to change runner goes pitch
is bounced up the middle right at the
second base bag and that'll be an easy
double play perfect placement turns into
two as buchet rolls out
and charlie morton very happy with that
result two for the price of one clears
the bases for guerrero on ball two
strikes
and there's the curve ball from charlie
morton that's more like it paul byrd's
scouting report right on point i'll lead
off single a double play and then matt
vlad whips the braves will get a look at
a guy that a lot of them have seen in
ross stripling 31 year old ross
stripling will make his fifth start of
the season third time he's opened up on
the road and he had a rough outing last
time out against houston day baseball
here in atlanta it'll be a cuna freeman
in ozuna for the brave swaying at a high
towering fly ball crushed to left by
acuna if it's fair it's gone he admires
that one as it lands in the hank aaron
terrace
his 21st career leadoff homer and with
one pitch ross stripling is down one to
nothing well that was a no doubter so
acuna with a big league leading 12 home
runs the braves again
do what they do first inning runs ball
into strike freeman and ozzy lead and a
line driving to right center field
that's down for a hit freddie broke back
to third he's now going to streak home
and score the throw comes to the plate
maguire drops it and adrianza moves up
an extra 90 feet so for strippling it's
more of the same he's given up two runs
he's given up three rockets
blue jays with something going two on
with one out in the second and jonathan
davis getting his start in center field
for randall grichik this afternoon 2-2
to davis and a swing in a ball line
softly left center and down for a base
hit rounding third and heading home as
biggio stopping at second is guriel and
a really good at bat for jonathan davis
to get the blue jays on the board you
try to make a pitch perfect that's when
you see missing
breaking ball fly ball well hit toward
left ozuna retreats to the warning track
he's got just enough room
samian almost turned the game around but
toronto gets a run back we're in the
second 2-1 game now atlanta tries to add
on again with pache who's looking for
his fourth hit since being called back
up from gwinnett
as this ball is hit hard towards short
machette throws on the run
toronto's defense has picked up no
errors in
their last five games let's take a look
apache running down the line see if we
notice anything watch his face here you
see how he grimaces christian pache has
left
today's game 26 strikeouts 25 walks for
vladimir and the pitch
is popped up
shallow left dansby goes out and makes
the over-the-shoulder catch
ozuna was there too not sure if dansby
had time to turn around but he makes the
catch for the second out i mean that's a
great job by dansby but that's right
there that's
azuna's got to be calling him off chip
running in full speed from left field
and you got a guy coming that's
that's the left fielder's ball all the
way and against a good offensive club
like toronto that's what you let them
stick around we've seen the last two
games
that's right three on a curveball four
strikeouts for morton bidgeo didn't
think so
fireworks go off here at truest park is
charlie has
outnumber one in the unit braves up two
to one bottom four dansby swanson who
struck out his first time up
2-2 there it is and it's right on the
corner for strike three called 162 games
is a long season a lot can change
2-2 and there's another strikeout strike
three called
eight strikeouts now for stripling with
bashan up
bow his double hit into a double play
and struck out runner at second two down
and a fastball lined into right field a
base hit for beshet maguire around third
and he will come in to score beshet
drives in the tying run for the blue
jays
and hernandez lines one off the glove of
albie's into center for a base hit
beshette can jog home and the blue jays
have taken a three to two lead for
stripling with two outs here in the
fifth
and he has really turned things around
now
nine strikeouts
one shy of his career high
[Music]
and freddie freeman pops one up
beshett going out davis coming in davis
is there and how about that
a neat and tidy three up three down
bottom of the fifth for ross stripling
and dansby swanson stands in he is the
final hope for the braves in the sixth
19th pitch of the inning is swung on and
hit high in the air that's deep left
toward that boat pan that ball is out of
here
two homers for atlanta acuna and swanson
and the braves leapfrog toronto and lead
it four to three every pitch he's
throwing with the fastballs had a lot of
run you try to come in there with a
fastball you better get in and off the
plate with how quick his hands are
he made him pay
[Applause]
swing and a high towering fly ball to
left ozuna is back and he is there
guerrero hit it too high and into the
teeth of the wind and that saved the
braves in the seventh time for the
stretch braves up a run in game three
cunha batting with two down on the bases
empty swings of the first pitch and a
roller up the third base line charging
vizio he gloves it cleanly throws to
first bang bang play and acuna is there
but he's hobbling up the right field
line
and he goes down to the ground out in
right field along the line i believe he
went across the bag awkwardly he's
holding his left ankle oh it looks like
his right toe
skimmed the inside of the bag and that
caused him to trip and land awkwardly
and now has to leave the game after
injuring an ankle third baseman for
margot is playing
fairly close to the line against the
left-handed batter here in vizio
the 0-1 and this one is lined up the
alley in right center field it is down
and it's all the way to the fence
tay oscar around third heading home and
will score without a throw as the biggio
double has tied it
well the blue jays in good shape right
now hoping to take the lead in the top
of the ninth inning two on nobody out
with bo buchet up
and he lines the ball into right center
field and this one is getting to the
fence
jensen into score simeon around third he
will score it's a two-run double for
buchet and it is 6-4 blue jays
3-2 and biggio hits it to deep right
field and it'll be off the wall on the
fly
and at second base is bishop with yet
another rbi double it's now seven to
four dan may be dealing with some major
outfield injury issues as goriel sends a
fly ball to center this ball is really
caring it'll be caught by adrianza on
the track
and hernandez can jog home with the
eighth run of the game for the blue jays
and it is jordan romano into the game he
comes in for the bottom of the ninth
trying to nail it down here for the blue
jays
bloody mimicking what romano does on the
mound now romano doesn't know he's doing
it but i bet you a bunch of the other
guys on the blue jay team know he's
doing it
absolutely they do that's awesome
they're on the verge of scraping the
braves all six games
and a fastball right down the middle at
99 to finish it